I went back recently. Uh,
Rachel Peterson is our chief researcher and she pulled up 35 pages of
material on the actual black lives matter organization.
And when you have these founded by three Marxists, uh,
and when you read about their real beliefs,
you begin to understand they live in an alternative worldview.
They live in a world where the police are really very dangerous and they don't
quite have an explanation for all the other people that get killed,
because you're, if you're an African-American male,
you're 300 times more likely to be shot by a criminal than by the police. Uh,
but that doesn't matter because you know,
the police are an extension of the authoritarian power of the white male
dominated culture, which is what they're really mad about.
This has come up with almost all of my guests,
because everyone at this point basically agrees that the media is crumbling.
They've done this to themselves. They,
they seem to double down every time instead of, you know,
having a moment of self-reflection. Uh,
but are you worried that if the New York times fails, if CNN,
if it just the media and then the rest of the institutions,
cause that then spreads to academia and everywhere else that if these
institutions all crumble, you know, you know,
we almost have no way of having a national ethos at some level.
Well, I look, I think there are other institutions that emerge.
I think there's an amazing amount of information now on the internet,
through Facebook and YouTube and a bride litter, all the Twitters, right?
There's a lot of hostility in it, but, uh, you know,
and then you have places like CSPAN, which really are, uh, remarkably neutral.
In fact, I have watched several Trump's speeches on C-SPAN.
You also have an ability to stream things. The president, uh,
strange a lot of his speeches and what's the now watch his speeches, uh,
as stream from the white house. We also, frankly, during the lockdown,
got into watching both the St Peter's, uh, and, uh, the Basilica in Washington,
because they were streaming mass.
So you're entering a world of dramatically more media,
not less than just as your show is another example of more media,
not less media, but we're going to have a really deep split because, uh,
we're in the middle of a cultural, civil war.
And it there's just no question in my mind that this is the most divided we've
been since the election of Lincoln in 1860 and his reelection in
1864. And that part of the reason I wrote, uh,
Trump and the American future is that I really do believe that
what happens this fall may do more to shape America's future
than any election since 1864. Uh,
and I say that because I think that the Biden
Polosi Schumer team will be so radical that
we would not recognize the country within two or three years,
they would have moved to so far to the left.
Do you think that it's the Schumer Pelosi team that are actually the true
radicals, or do you think it's the,
it's the Bernie crew and the AOC crew beneath them?
That's sort of just shifting them that way or do you really feel like they are
actually that radical?
It's a little hard to tell these days if they're a little more old school and
the, you know, the tail is wagging the dog, basically.
Yeah. I mean, a little bit like saying when you got,
when you got run over by the truck, you know,
do you think the driver was deliberately trying to robbery or
you got run over, um, when Schumer,
the other day came out for the 10% cut in defense spending,
which Sanders is operating as an amendment. Uh,
and when Pelosi brought up a bill, which 207 Democrats voted for,
that gives a $1,200 bonus to every illegal immigrant.
I want you to think about this 207 Democrats voted to give a
$1,200 bonus check to every illegal immigrant.
I mean, you have to wonder that these people just crazy, um,
Biden who said that he would, uh, sign the Pelosi bill,
which was a $3 trillion, very radical bill. Um,
you certainly didn't see Biden, uh, criticizing, uh,
the looters and the violence. In fact,
13 of Biden's staff actually helped bail out looters and violent
people in, uh, Minneapolis. Uh, so I just,
you know, I think there's a pattern in, in, uh, Trump and the American future.
I put in, uh,
a chapter that the Democrats love criminals and hate beliefs.
And I think if you look at Seattle, Minneapolis, Chicago, New York,
I think that that's the objective evidence.
So as we watch these progressive cities crumble,
the several you just named there, and we can, we can go on the list,
all the cities with the worst violence and the worst gun violence and the
highest rates of murders there, they're all, I think,
19 out of 20 or something like that are progressive run cities.
Do you sense that sort of what those mayors and the governors to another
extent want is they want the chaos so that Trump has to bring in
troops or the national guard,
like they're almost laying out a trap so that he looks like the authoritarian
that they wish him to be.
No, I, I think, um, I mean, I don't think they mind that happening,
but I don't think that's what they're doing.
I think that the left really has this fantasy image of how the
world works. And they really think that if only there were no policemen,
instead, it's sort of like the,
the democratic mayor of Seattle who said that we were going to have a summer of
love when they created the autonomous district.
Now four people got killed and she gave up on that. Although ironically,
she didn't really give up on it until the demonstrators came to her home one
night. And then when they were surrounding her house, that's what she said,
something that's true. But I think, um,
part of it is that they're, they're radical left-wing ideology.
Doesn't allow them to deal with reality.
So you end up with a let's cut the budget of the New York police department of
billion dollars when there were, I think, um,
13 people shot. Yeah. On Monday. Uh,
Chicago has few too few policemen, not too many,
and they have a dozen or more people shot every weekend. Um,
you know, after all the problems in Minneapolis, they're now moving to, uh,
dissolve the police department. And, and, and to my mind,
you know, if you, if you stop and say, wait, walk me through this. Uh,
there's an armed gunman. Uh, it's two o'clock in the morning.
You're going to send social workers, the chat with the Gutman.
I just need to understand how their worldview works, but I've,
but I've, I went back recently, uh,
Rachel Peterson is our chief researcher and she pulled up 35 pages of
material on the actual black lives matter organization.
And when you have these founded by three Marxist, uh,
and when you read about their real beliefs,
you begin to understand they live in an alternative worldview.
They live in a world where the police are really very dangerous and they don't
quite have an explanation for all the other people get killed. Cause you're,
if you're an African-American male,
you're 300 times more likely to be shot by a criminal than by the police. Uh,
that doesn't matter because you know,
the police are an extension of the authoritarian power of the white male
dominated culture, which is what they're really mad about.
Whereas if you just have them get killed by your neighbor,
that doesn't really count. So, you know,
an eight year old girl gets killed in Atlanta. Well, that's unfortunate,
but it's not something that black lives matter is going to do anything about,
but she wasn't killed by a policeman. Seven year old gets killed in Chicago.
Well, that's really unfortunate,
but it's not really a political event cause she wasn't killed by a policeman.
So you really have this very weird period underway where the left has
no model to explain how they would achieve peace
just as, by the way,
they have no model to explain how they would educate children.
You look at Baltimore, which has the fourth,
most expensive school system in the country and has entire
buildings and watch not a single child can pass the exam.
Not one to which a Biden's comments this week were.
Maybe we need to quit, um, testing because after all, uh,
probably makes them feel bad that they didn't pass the test.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.